I want to get your thoughts on this a
few people emailed me and they said hey
David did you see what happened when
Sean Spicer Trump's White House press
secretary talked about the meeting with
Canadian Prime Minister Joe Trudeau and
if you're saying to yourself why is
David saying Joe Trudeau his name is
Justin Trudeau that's exactly what it is
that Sean Spicer said so there's
differing opinions about whether this is
Spicer and lack of preparedness or just
sort of a verbal glitch let's listen to
it together and then we'll discuss
yesterday the president said had a
incredibly productive set of meetings
and discussions with Prime Minister
Trudeau of Canada focusing on our shared
commitment to close cooperation okay so
it's unclear whether he said Joe Trudeau
or whether he sort of stumbled while
saying Trudeau but this happened more
than once throughout the day for Sean
Spicer is this snow small little thing
doesn't matter no big deal or is it part
of a broader constant lack of
preparedness from the Trump
administration you've watched this a
couple of times Pat what do you think I
think he's just stumbling over the word
Trudeau I mean he was stammering early
on in that sentence I think he went to
say Prime Minister Trudeau but got
stumbled up on the truck part and I
think he said I think he just tried to
say Trudeau there that's my I'm not
really sure and the thing is whether
this was just a stumble or not it was
widely reported as Trump press secretary
refers to Justin Trudeau as Joe Trudeau
and if it weren't for the fact that
there's this longer well longer we're on
day 26 of the Trump administration it
feels like it's been years if not
decades because of how much craziness
has gone on but there's been a total
lack of preparedness from the Trump
White House in so many ways when British
Prime Minister Theresa May came to
Washington into the White House
in three different places her first name
Teresa was misspelled without the H
which in and of itself is a little bit
embarrassing to not spell the name of a
foreign leader correctly but it just so
happens that Theresa May with no H
happens to be a British porn star so
completely embarrassing
for the Trump Whitehouse Donald Trump
totally unprepared during phone calls
with foreign leaders he had to pause a
phone call with Russian leader Vladimir
Putin to ask what the nuclear treaty was
that the United States has with Russia
to only then get back on the call and
say oh yeah Obama started that I'm
against it
typos and errors everywhere and then the
press secretary appears to say the wrong
name for a world leader and not one from
halfway around the world but one that is
just a few hundred miles north of where
we are in Boston Massachusetts so you
know I think the thing is Pat that
there's again this broader idea that the
White House at every single level is a
group of people that are in way over
their heads and are messing up in ways
that nobody could ever predict I mean
they're also messing up in the ways that
that all rational people predicted but
this is sort of low-hanging fruit that
you'd think they'd be able to avoid yeah
I guess we'll never really know I mean
I'm more skeptical about it in this
instance but if true it kind of goes to
this narrative that the people inside
the Trump administration don't really
know what they're doing and shouldn't be
in that position
next week reportedly Donald Trump will
be meeting with the German Chancellor
Andrea Merkel and the French president
Francois Amsterdam that that is the
latest press conference from Sean Spicer
I'm kidding please don't email me city
mail me saying that I'm spreading fake
news that's a joke it's not real today's
episode of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in too I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS